I definitely have to ask when you're
doing an outfit like Padme like this
um how much are people helping you and
how much is this actually all you this
is not me at all so okay I I went to the
costume team well I mentioned actually
to to uh my wardrobe assistant Kate uh
last week oh yeah celebration's coming
up I think that I'm gonna dress up as
Padme because I love cons and I love to
cosplay she was like oh cool cool maybe
I'll mention it to the costume team okay
came to work on Monday and they had the
entire outfit for me like down to the
Belt like they surprised me and as in
his um our one of our our wardrobe
artists Amanda Cox it was her last day
and so she gave it to me as a present so
I can't take any credit for it like they
they're just so incredible and kind uh
yeah you'll be wearing this to Comic-Con
in other places because it's fantastic I
surprised him about making a Star Wars
show that you did expect going in
oh
um
well something sure something technical
that I can speak to
um I thought because of how Mandalorian
was shot that maybe we'd be shooting on
a volume but we shoot on practical sets
so probably the thing that's been the
most shocking for me is walking onto
these humongous practical sets that have
been created just for our world and and
I've never had that experience before
you know I've been on of course amazing
sets in in my career but there's nothing
like this what is it like walking into a
Jedi Temple seeing all the books and
does your character open any of them and
get knowledge uh that will pertain to
the future episodes I can't stand you
I have actually spent time in a Jedi
Temple I took a nap in there once
wild just on just on the marble slab
like just kind of looking out on a
course not
um that's all I did in there though
sure
um talk a little bit about the what do
you think will the footage look amazing
what do you think fans are actually
going to be
um
most excited when they see it because
it's obviously such a different show
than anything that else that's come
before it
I think
I think all the fan
cited about
about existing in the high Republic uh
point in the timeline and and that's
probably one of the most exciting things
for me too is is because it's it's a an
era that hasn't been explored in live
action at least
um it it allows for us to create really
complex
um kind of morally morally ambiguous and
complex characters well one of the
things about the high Republic is that
the Jedi at the time were basically
their power was unchecked it was I mean
they're literally the I gotta wrap up
with you but sort of talk a little bit
about that
right
um you no one else has hit me with this
like I have respect for you
um
well
um I think that you're definitely onto
something I've what you're like I know
um I I think that that is what is so
fascinating at this point in time what
does it look like when the Jedi have
complete unchecked power
um what are their relationships like to
government institutions you know and and
then people who have issues with their
power what are they like
on that note I'm just going to say uh
good luck with the speed dating and I
really can't wait to see the series
thank you